what do you think about this United
Airlines incident where they banned two
girls they threw them off the plane
because they were wearing leggings the
leg yeah and now that they sense
retracted that but what did you make of
that whole thing I mean that's just it
was nonsense
it was crazy you know that's another
thing of trying to tell women what to do
and it's anything it has like a sexist
quality thing cuz look I was on a flight
once and Richard Simmons was on the
plane and he was wearing that tank top
and those nasty little shiny shorts was
he really hey this is a true story I
swear he got on the plane he was right
we have a picture English short he was
wearing a baby he was sitting in first
class and his drawers yeah sitting there
sitting in his underwear yeah yeah and
I'm like oh he shouldn't even be able to
get past TSA like that right on that's
that's like just very unhealthy and yeah
okay like this was like three years ago
right so because now I know people don't
can't find him he's missing
well he's not missing currently they the
word is they they found him and he just
wants to stay in his house he doesn't
want to be a public person anymore what
do you think of that I get that I get
that you know cuz some days you know I'm
sick of me you know like some days you
just look at yourself and like yeah I'm
pretty sure Richard civis probably had
one of those moments he probably got up
and had his a little outfit on and then
looked at himself in the mirror was like
what are we doing
[Laughter]
what are we doing what are we doing all
right
prancing around nutso hanging all right
for God's sake for God's sake let's take
a break
[Laughter]
you